cabinets of curiosities became a form of
storytelling there was such a belief
that you could accumulate sort of
samples and pieces of the world's
knowledge and and the world's most
interesting things under one roof yes
you know and there is a beautiful
magical will there to me the most
fascinating collection is William
Beckford who wrote one of the great
gothic novels Pathak and he and he
created his own magical world font Hill
Abbey where he created an extravagant
architectural wonder and filled it with
everything that he could buy from
everywhere in the world he had obviously
specimens from nature freaks pickled
punks animals dissected animals stuffed
animals paintings maps it was it's it's
a place I dream of and actually a place
I sort of patterned my house yes after
you know it's not I'm not as opulent as
back for it he was a very rich heir but
I do I do every time I check arrives
half of it goes immediately to my wife I
say do not let me touch it and I then
say don't ask me anything about the
other you know I think what's
interesting about cabinets have wonder
cabinets of curiosity is that they were
in a sense scientific they were
gathering specimens but of all kinds but
they were also cabinets of wonder so it
was science as as Wonder and it brings
those two sides and there were full of
things said by the way I think they were
full of fabrications because I think
that there is a moment in which man mmm
tries to distinguish the you know the
rift between science and myth and the
cabinets of curiosities still embrace
the fact that there shouldn't be any
rift right and I and I do think that the
narrative of science the one that has
made us cross the oceans climb the
mountains and go to the moon has a bit
of fancy you know when we make science
boring and we say science denies every
other possibility when when science
becomes a medicine for the ill mind and
it tries to stop us from imagining I
find it sad because science made us
dream you know and when I was a kid I
was there when the first man landed on
the moon I was a kid and and we dreamt
and it was Jules Verne yes partially
that got us to the moon absolutely it
was Ray Harryhausen that got us to the
moon and we want to stop that frontier
and we have to know that within science
there is poetry yes and if we lose that
I think is urgent that we don't that we
we have such wonders right now we have
basically in our back pocket a more
advanced communication device than the
3/4 and Star Trek yes a hundred times
more powerful than any computer in 1960
70 you know like you you really have
NASA and the CIA together had nothing on
one app in the iPhone and yet and yet I
think that the one urgent thing we have
to have is feed or curiosity and for
that I think collecting is a testament
to that I in movies in movies collecting
came from the fact that before movies
were downloadable and easily available
they became an almost religious act they
had an ephemeral nature and you knew
that you didn't catch that movie at that
time the only way you could recreate the
experience was if you bought the
soundtrack on an LP if you had the
poster or a lobby card or if you read
about it in magazines that were
fetishistic about it like Famous
Monsters of Filmland so so that that
became or iconography in the religious
sense and collecting about memorabilia
it was a way to reconnect with that
moment